foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I know
I am the same
for he touched me
oh he touched me
a joke
[Music]
something
happened
and now
[Music]
me oh
we all never cease
never cease to praise him
[Music]
my soul
nothing
[Music]
foreign
for all the Dew
is still on the roads
are here
[Music]
with me
and the joy
as ever
his works
and the Sun
love is born
is so sweet
home
is
foreign
[Music]
never
mind every day
[Music]
foreign
whole
food
[Music]
s
sister
[Music]
foreign
ah
how sweet
love
the Sun
say
like me
[Music]
but
I'm not
I'm fine
wow
one night
I can see
me
[Music]
hi
this
[Music]
is
be safe
we
[Music]
with me
thank you
[Music]
but thanks
welcome to Graceland the forever home of
Elvis in the summary Presley
We Gather here today from all over the
world to honor and celebrate the life of
Lisa Marie Presley who's taken from us
much too soon
lease had given many instructions for
this day her desires and wishes of which
I will share with you one
don't make it sad
Lisa we will try to honor you
and honor your wish today
if you would bow your hits please
As We Gather today to celebrate the life
of me similarly Presley
while her light has gone out please give
light to her children and her mother
so that they can rise above the darkness
of this grief
let them be strengthened by the presence
of the many who have gathered with them
today to share their sorrow
and even in this time of pain we are
grateful for the beautiful gift that was
Lisa Marie her passion her strength her
Brilliance and her tenaciousness
and let the memories share today and the
word spoken today bring joy to our
hearts may we all experience your peace
in our pain your healing in our hurt
your light in our Darkness
and the name of this place where we
stand Graceland reminds us to be
thankful for grace that gives us
strength Even in our weakness
so let immeasurable love abound in this
place and make perfect peace abide in
our hearts
foreign
good morning
and it is a good morning
because we're we're here
we're all here because we want to be
here
probably some other places we could have
been but this is where we
want to be
and whenever I hear where you really
it's a good morning
I've never been told so many times to
keep it short
and I'll try to honor that
but when you're
paying tribute to
someone with whom you connected in a way
that no one else
witnessed
and now
you won't connect
in this place
in that same way
ever again
I've been here a bunch of times
but never on occasion like this and
although I'm still smiling for those who
you can't see
I'm honoring
you wish
to the family
all of you
it's a pleasure for me to be here
and as you notice on the back of the
program
contribute to the children
I know that Lisa would want you to honor
the request to give to the children of
Saint Jude please honor that
before Dennis Quaid and
Meg Ryan hat Jack
before Kurt Russell and
go to Han had Wyatt
before Lenny Kravitz and Lisa Bonet had
Zoey
before pink
and Corey Hart had Willow
and yes
before Jay-Z and Beyonce
had blue eyes
and long before Harry and Megan had
aren't you right here
right here
in this city
our own royal couple
Elvis and Priscilla
had a beautiful bundle of joy
named Lisa Marie
it was 1968.
it was the best of times and the worst
of times
their trying times in our city
Dr King was assassinated in 1968.
that was the worst of times
many of you here remember that period
truly one of the most trying times
in the history of our nation
God knows
it was hard it was a hard year for
Memphis
but 54 years ago
there was a star shining right here at
Graceland
with the birth of this precious angel
in fact
Lisa Marie's birth
is woven into the institutional memory
and historical social
of this city
think about that for a moment
she was and remained the only child
born
to the worlds most famous farmer
she was a conduit to the throne The
Keeper of the flame
she was the image of a king
she was that special
now
I don't know much about Hollywood can't
speak for Hollywood
can't speak for New York
or any other City
or at least I may have spent time
but I can tell you that Lisa Marie
was this it is precious Jewel
every day of her life
in fact
and the way we talk around you and we
say
down south
Lisa Marie was what many folks would
call our own place sister
or play cousin
if some of you who are not from around
here find that a little strange let me
just break it down for you
you have people who have played
relatives
that's an individual who's just tied to
you
in an Inseparable way
that you call them a part of your family
and the only reason you use that term
play sister or brother is to let
everyone know
that the bond is not really blood the
bond is affection it's love
in the final analysis
it's not your decision to choose your
siblings
that's what grown folks do
but your place sister
is somebody you choose
and we chose Lisa's our play daughter
our place sister not of blood
but of love and affection she was that
special to us
she was not only
the King's Daughter
she was our City's choice
and y'all have heard me say this before
Elvis may have been born in
Tupelo
and Priscilla
may have starred on Dallas
but Lisa Marie
was all Memphis
she belonged to us and we belonged to
her we kept her in our hearts
and we saw her at such a young age
deal with the weight of Fame
and deal with
grief
the joy
Peaks
as we're on this hill a peak
but just a few feet down is the valley
and she was on the peaks of life
but she knows she knew that there was
hurt in the valley
yet she dealt with
today
as I wrap this up
we celebrate her love
we admire her Artistry we embrace
her family
and we recognize the strength
and sheer force
cheer force or will
it took for Lisa just to
keep on climbing
when Elvis was a young man
he used to visit East Ridge Baptist
Church in South Memphis
where the pastor was a brilliant black
man named Reverend Dr William Herbert
Brewster
the music in the place was amazing
because in addition to being a
tremendous past and preacher
Dr Brewster was the Gifted songwriter
whose prolific pen
helped to propel gospel singers careers
to Soaring Heights
he was always also playwright in the
poet let me leave you with his words
and then
when I come to the end of life's way
and my son goes down at the close of the
day
all weary and worn
I shall cling to my shield
though I won't be heralded a claim to be
a hero in the field
in the cool of the evening
I shall come to my rest
in the sweet conclusion
I've done my best
so as a body finds rest at Graceland
and as her soul by grace
takes flight
her spirit will live in the collective
memory
of a city
that loved her tenderly
loved her sweetness
and loved her truly
do I like things
foreign
[Music]
real
strong
strong feel
you'll make me
real
Sheila rise
I'm crashing that again
intake I
passed
with blushing brilliance
alive
[Music]
cause it's time
time to arrive
yeah
make me
real
you'll make me rain
strong as I feel
you'll
make me
lately I just can't seem to believe
discard my friends to change the scenery
it man flew out to hold a bruising faith
now it's just a matter of Grace
a summer storm
Grace is All of Me
[Music]
I went wrong
and I could bring
the light
[Music]
take you home and to the nights
foreign
[Music]
strong
as I feel
you
know me
real
[Music]
foreign
okay so AC Wharton that was incredible
really was we you talked about
you talked about the flames and I think
it's time that we all need to stoke our
Flames within to do what Joel said which
was to celebrate this extraordinary Lisa
Marie and
I stand here with great honor because we
called each other and I've been
with you being with you all for all all
your lives really and I stand here with
great honor but uh so this is for
you with affection
my late mother-in-law used to say that
nothing can be said can begin to take
away the anguish and the pain of these
moments because grief is the price we
pay for love
and how right she was and today we talk
about Lisa Marie we look at Priscilla as
a mother as a mother to Lisa Marie we
look to Lisa Marie and say you lost a
son
mothers losing children
it there are no words for it
so today we talk about action and action
is the way we can go forward we can
light the flame
so for Riley
for Harper and Finley and for the entire
family
we March forward in support of you all
of us are with you and we will help you
as best you can if you just put out your
hand we will be there or well I will
definitely be there
so David Frost died and George Frost was
his son and I asked George if I could
read it today and it's for you
I've had my life and enjoyed every
second
but as it is another life has beckoned
it's important to know that I've not
gone
and I hope that on you all my light has
shone
stay in that sunshine
rest never in the shade
don't curse my absence
as this light you'll evade
I live in the smiles
the moon the stars and sky
and I feel Eternal Pride as I watch you
all fly
and for my darling children who wonder
what to do
just have a wonderful time
as I will living through you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you should be a coward but I am a
warrior
with many voices in my head
and I looked around and I reached out
I saw no alternative
[Music]
you miss us
he's been pushing for a while
can we cut this man some slack and let
them lying down
let them lie down
we are a countries that spread for the
embryonic
I'm called and I'm hungry and I yearn
for a handle my forehead
thank you
you think it's a walk in the park and
it's easy she's got it as good as it
gets
dismiss understanding the line between
living
[Music]
and God Rest
God please rest ourselves
[Music]
she's been pushing for a while
can we cut this one slack and let her
lie down
[Music]
the more that you hurl at me
the more I will curl up in my bed
foreign
[Music]
me
we've been hurting for a while
can we cut ourselves some slack and let
us slide down
let them lie down
letter lie down
let us lie down
foreign
first of all
I want to thank the family
the Presley family
Priscilla
Riley
Harper and Findlay
I want to thank Jack Selden and
everybody at Elvis Presley Enterprises
I want to thank Joel weinshaker
and ABG
everybody making this possible
me
and a girl named Memphis
I always call Lisa Memphis
she had that attitude
and she always called me
Jerry Schilling always in that Cadence
her son been stormed at the same thing
Jerry Schilling
in 1967
Elvis invited me back here to Graceland
for Christmas and New Year's
as I was leaving to go back to L.A and
back to work
he looked at me and he said
you're not going to stay for the birth
of our daughter
I said I guess I will so I was here
until February 1st
still got my job
we got back
so we remember we got back to the
to the house here
and I
had never held a baby before and we're
in the kitchen
and Elvis Just hands me Lisa
and I sure as hell wasn't going to drop
her you know
and that was
the beginning
of my journey with Memphis
never on this wonderful that you're here
too my friend
we spend a lot of time together
in her childhood days and as she grew up
one thanks uh giving day
at her mom's
she said I need to have a meeting with
you
I don't know if she was 18 or 19 percent
like that yeah
and uh so I said okay so we went to an
exclusive place the hamburger Hamlet
and she said
I need a job
and I and she said I know people don't
think I'm responsible but I really am
and God bless her she really was
she became my secretary
at any time you said that she would
always correct me I'm your assistant
we started working out of my home I had
a couple of other people in Lake Kuroda
that was in my staff and then we
eventually moved to offices on Sunset
Strip
where she had many responsibilities
one of which was to answer all the phone
calls that would come into me
and I don't know about every couple of
weeks she would come in a very
disgruntled look on her face
somebody else wants to talk to you about
Lisa Marie they had no idea they were
talking to her on the phone
so
we had fun with that
um
at the time
uh
I was managing uh
another mission if you will Jerry Lee
Lewis and uh
and Memphis was the only person I knew
who could intimidate
Jerry Lee Lewis
so Danny you may remember this after a
jury Lewis concert one night we went to
dinner
at Le Dome
and she said
Jerry Lee
what's this I heard about you ran into
the gates of Graceland it was the first
time ever saw Jerry Lee Lewis
speechless and nervous but she could do
it she just had that way
as Lisa's first manager
I always
from the garage music you guys did Danny
I always believed in her
as both a singer and a songwriter
one of the very first songs she co-wrote
with Danny
was call give me the strength
which has a special meaning
always to me especially today because I
think at that young age
it was almost the gospel feel that she
she knew she would need strength to go
through life
I was also honored and proud when asked
to perform Lisa's wedding
Riley been sweating
more recent never on sweating
so I have a nickname within the family
they call me rev Jay
I would like to end with
recently on a Sunday afternoon after she
had left Memphis on her father's 88th
birthday
she asked me if I would walk her
on the red carpet
to the Golden Globes the following
Tuesday
afterwards as we walked to the car
the last thing she said to me
Jerry Schilling
I love you
as I was in the hospital with her father
when Priscilla was giving birth
I was at the hospital
with her mother when she left us
Memphis
I will always love you thank you
foreign
I'm Blown Away how many people are here
today
that was beautiful
really
um
I'm going to read something that
my granddaughter
wrote
for all of you
and this says it all
the old soul
I have no idea how to put my mother into
words
truth is there are too many
Lisa Marie Presley was an icon a role
model a superhero to many people all
over the world
but mama was my icon
my role model My Superhero
in much more ways than one
even now I can't get across everything
there is to be understood or known about
her
but as she always said
I'll do my best
the old soul this is a poem
the old soul
in 1968 she entered our world born tired
fragile yet strong
she was delicate but was filled with
life
she always knew she wouldn't be here too
long
childhood passes by
with a glimpse of her green eye
she then grew a family of her own
then came her second child
leaving her with suspicion could this be
the angel that takes me home
time of course flew by it was time for a
tragedy
she knew what was close to the end
survivors
guilt some would say but a broken heart
was a doing of her death
now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love
she knew that I loved her
I fear I'll never touch her but the
other soul is always with me
she doesn't drift above
that says it all
and thank you all for being here never
own your brother
thank you for being here
and the family of course and all of you
our heart is broken Lisa we all love you
thank you
I'm going to read something Riley wrote
a letter to my mama
thank you for being my mother in this
life I am eternally grateful to have
spent 33 years with you
I'm certain I chose the best mother for
me in this world and I knew that as far
back as I can remember you
I remember everything
I remember you giving me baths as a baby
I remember you driving me in my car seat
listening to Aretha Franklin
I remember the way you would cuddle me
and when I'd come into your bed at night
and the way you smelled
I remember you taking me for ice cream
after school in Florida
I remember you singing me and my brother
lullabies at night and how you'd lay
with us until we fell asleep
I remember how every time you'd leave
town you'd bring me a new tea set from
Cracker Barrel
I remember all the notes you'd leave in
My Lunchbox every day
I remember the feeling I'd get when I'd
see you picking me up from school
the way your hand felt on my forehead
I remember how it felt to be loved by
the most loving mother I've ever known
I remember how safe it felt to be in
your arms
I remember that feeling as a child and I
remember it two weeks ago on your couch
thank you for showing me that love is
the only thing that matters in this life
I hope I can love my daughter the way
you loved me
the way you loved my brother my sisters
thank you for giving me strength my
heart my empathy my courage my sense of
humor my manners my temper my wildness
my tenacity
I'm a product of your heart
my sisters are a product of your heart
my brother is a product of your heart
we are you you are us my eternal love
I hope you finally know how Loved You
Were Here
thank you for trying so hard for us
if I didn't tell you every day thank you
foreign
I knew if I was invited I needed to come
to these ceremonies I hadn't planned on
speaking and when I was put on the spot
I really didn't know what to say
and I was I was tongue-tied and nervous
and I don't even really know what I said
but
I as I'm sure many of you are are still
in shock
as I feel I'll continue to be for quite
some time
I feel like I'm supposed to be texting
her like right now saying I'm here
telling her how how wonderful everyone
is
[Music]
I know in a million years imagine
singing
here and especially under these
circumstances
this is truly devastating and I'm sure
excruciating for everyone here and all
of those affected by our passing
at the same time
one can see how hard everyone's worked
and is working to make this as beautiful
for Lisa as it can be and is
I'm honored to be here for Lisa and her
family
I didn't I don't know that I deserve to
be here especially speaking amongst
those that have known Lisa for longer
and were much closer than her and I
especially her family and those that
have known her most of their lives or
even all of hers
I do know Lisa loved her family very
much
and was fiercely protective of her
father his legacy and both her love for
him and his love for her she was
extremely proud as proud as anyone could
ever be of her father and as many
accomplishments his place in music
America
An American in world history
she was also very proud of the Elvis
movie and how she felt it portrayed her
father and the care that was put into
the film by those involved Mr lerman's
vision and Direction and Austin Butler's
dedication to the role of her father
with Ben's passing Lisa's life and the
rest of her family and his loved ones
took a turn down a hard road that she
was honoring for the
honoring to the best of her abilities
seeking out help and choosing to help
others who experienced or experiencing
such a such a loss and pain
we are gathered here today to pay our
respects to Lisa and her family
and to share our memories console one
another to the degree that we're able
and though under such difficult
heartbreaking and somber circumstances
also to celebrate the life of a friend
a loved one
a beautiful and good soul and a
cherished and deeply missed family
member
Lisa's loved and missed by many and will
continue to be loved and missed by all
those whose lives she touched
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
cause nothing lasts forever and I'm
about my hearts can change
and it's hard to hold a candle in the
courtroom in the rain
well been through the such a long long
time just trying to kill the pain
but love has always come my love was
always
[Music]
foreign
but I know
don't you know you need some time
all alone
I know it's hard to keep an open heart
even for
[Music]
them friend but if you could
you could broken heart
wouldn't tie me out to charm you
[Music]
know
thank you
do you need some time on your own
but do you need some time all alone
[Music]
foreign
I know that you can love me when there's
no one left to blame
so never mind the darkness because we
still can find a way
cause nothing lasts forever
[Music]
foreign
God of comfort
console the hearts that are broken
and those who struggle with the Deep
pain of grief because of the certain
loss of Lisa Marie
God of Peace
be close to those who were close to her
and give them peace and strength
in the loss of their dear precious
loving mother
the beautiful daughter
and loyal friend
God of Hope
even though today we sit in the shadow
of loss
do not let us lose the hope that the
light will shine tomorrow
God of joy
wipe away the tears and let the
cherished memories of Lisa Marie bring
joy to our hearts
and keep us in the celebration of her
life
god of love fill our hearts as we commit
Lisa Marie Presley
to her final resting place
next to her son
and near to her father
and so we say goodbye
goodbye until tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
tell you never
Universe
display
then he sees my
soul my savior God to
thee
the world
[Music]
my
soul my savior God to thee
how great thou
[Music]
thou how great thou
art
How Will I
that God is so not scary
sent him to die
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
men
in the spring of 1968 I was a young
teenager growing up here in Memphis and
my dad was James Blackwood of the
Blackwood Brothers quartet and
um
I'll never forget one night I was at
home the phone rang and my ears perked
up when he said my dad said well hi
Elvis
and that was not unusual Elvis would
sometimes call and he would say Mr
Blackwood can you get the quartet
together and come out and I'm dying to
sing some old gospel songs and so they'd
stay up till all hours of the morning
singing but this this phone call is a
little different my dad hung up and he
said Elvis wants to introduce me to his
baby girl do you want to go with me
and I said of course so we came out here
and
Parts went in we rushed into the foyer
and a little bit Elvis came down the
steps holding Lisa in his arms
he said uh Mr Blackwood this is a
this is my my little girl Lisa Marie he
said Lisa this is Mr Blackwood one of my
heroes
I stood there just in awe I'm transfixed
you know not saying anything kind of
taking in the moment
several years before that my dad had
gotten a call and
Gladys had passed away and Elvis and
Vernon had requested that the Blackwood
Brothers sing at her funeral which they
were honored to do and then my dad sang
at Elvis's funeral as well so
this is kind of Full Circle
we are so honored to be here and to be a
part of Lisa's celebration today
there's a song that uh Elvis often had
sung in his concerts and he he actually
didn't sing it he would listen
as the Imperials and then later the
stamps would sing this song and he would
ask the audience just to be quiet and
listen and
as this song was sung a holy hush would
fill the
auditoriums
our prayer is that that same holy hush
would fill this place today and
Priscilla
Riley
Finley and Harper our hearts are with
you we're all here today because we love
your family
you're in her thoughts and prayers may
this song be the ushering end of God's
peace and presence in your life we pray
there's a sweet
sweet spirit
in this place
[Music]
of the Lord
there are sweet
Expressions holy
[Music]
spirit
s
[Music]
and I know
that it's the presence
of the Lord foreign
[Music]
foreign
for these blessings
praise
[Music]
please
thank you to all those who honored Lisa
Marie today by speaking and performing
it would have meant so much to her
thank you for all who came from all over
the world to come here to celebrate her
life
the meaning of existence is to reconcile
Liberty with service the passing with
the lasting to weave the threads of the
temporary into the fabric of Eternity
Graceland allows for just that
and Lisa's voice will only be Amplified
with time and never be silenced or
diminished
she was and will always be her father's
protector
and we will continue to be hers
as we arrange for people to visit with
Lisa I ask everyone both in the media
and all of the people who come here
today to respect the family's wishes to
not be photographed or videoed this is
something that you can show your respect
to Lisa by not doing
we will arrange in groups obviously
starting with the family and the friends
please wait for your group to be
Shepherd to there thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
hallelujah
salvation in glory
honor and power
unto the Lord our God
for the Lord our God is mighty yes the
Lord our God is omnipotent
the Lord our
[Music]
he is one for
help me
[Music]
foreign
he is one see always
[Music]
and the Lord
He is wonderful
[Music]
things
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my God
[Music]
he's wonderful
time let's see
here
is
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
once I stood
and the night with my head but alone
in the Darkness
[Music]
and my heart
felt alone
and I cried
oh Lord
don't hide
your family
[Music]
hold my hands
take my hands
[Music]
[Applause]
alone
[Music]
like a king
with great riches
too cold
my own
but I don't
know a thing
in this world
alone
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]